[Applause]
yeah definitely pleasure to be here
my name is today and I'm a lead machine
learning engineer at open capacity we do
smart public transport with the use of
AI but today I'm going to focus on a
state of the art and I'd be library
called Flair and give you like a
high-level overview of maybe how it
works and also how to build models with
it so Flair is again one of the many NLP
libraries but in many ways it's very
different from all the others
it offers most of the usual tools you
would expect from a natural language
processing library but the thing I
really like about it is that it's super
simple so most of the tasks are usually
one liner or two liners so predicting
usually using using a preacher in
classifier is a one-liner tasks and
training a new embedding for example is
a four liner task which I find pretty
amazing and on top of all that it's a
cheap state of the art results in
several natural language processing
tasks it also comes with a few
pre-trained models and also few
embeddings like Bert and Elmo and it
also features a few of its own text
embeddings which I'm going to talk about
now so I think this is the the secret
sauce of the whole package flap and I
think in two ways in which the first two
other more conventional word based
embeddings that we use these days is how
it treats context and how its character
level language model as opposed to word
level language model and the way through
its context is interesting because if he
is one of the more conventional
embedding approaches that people use
today like word to back or a lot for
example we would use pre-computed
word vectors for glove for example and
we would extract an embedding for a
particular but regardless of what
context that word is used in for example
whereas if we use compact contextual
Obelix the input of our embedding is
actually the whole sentence and the
result is just embedding for that one
word that were interested in and based
on that we can generate different
embeddings for the same word based on
what context it's in more on that later
but the second really important
characteristic about contextual string
of endings is that there are character
level based so usually there are input
of a word embedding system would be a
sequence of words whereas here we use
secret sequence of characters the
important thing here is that a sequence
of words assumes that we have a
predefined vocabulary so usually we'll
have a problem of out of vocabulary
words and misspellings and prefixes and
new words and imaginary what
whereas this character based approach
can work both with misspellings and with
new words that just don't happen to be
in the vocabulary at a particular moment
so the approach that proposing the paper
also implemented in Flour uses
contextual string a balance between
approach called stacking so we actually
use a combination of several words and
character embeddings so in this example
we can see how word the word Washington
is is embedded and it's vector
presentation is extracted from the whole
sentence so we use a combination of two
different embedding so the first one is
the forward character in bedding which
is the red one that uses everything up
to the last character of Washington and
then we have the backwards embedding
that uses everything from the end of the
word until the first word of the word
Washington and then we stack them
together
is a fancy word for uncle catenae ting
the embedding vectors and there would be
like a high-level approach of how
embeddings are used with flat the
project achieved state-of-the-art
resource was actually a combination of
forward character language model
backward language character
backwards character language model and
glove so this is something we use in our
own text classification model that we
tried just for fun it's one of the most
straightforward approaches to use i'm so
here for example you can see code
snippet on how to train a custom text
classification model with flair and
first of course you need to define the
corpus which uses fast text formats
introduce fast attacks that should be
pretty straightforward and afterwards we
define the actual stack of word
embeddings that we used
so there's be a one-liner of course we
need to achieve document embeddings to
create a document classifier and for
that we use an lsdm approach that
included in flair and with a another
one-liner we can then train the model
here it's important to note that Flair
offers a variety of hyper parameters
that we can try and if you want but here
in this example we just use the default
parameters it also features a hyper
parameter optimization library which is
built on top of hyperope so if you do
striper out before I should definitely
be familiar with it here's another
example how to use app written text
classifies
another three liner so this is
everything you need to do to know the
sentiment analysis mother which if I
remember correctly to three years ago
was a huge task where companies had to
pay thousands so what cannot be done
like three lines and now I'm just going
to show you like how we can use the our
own spam and text classifier that we use
so the usage is really trivial so on
but it's still very fun to see work in
production so we trained this fam MTAC
slash fire
that classifies text messages into spam
or hem up so we can try something that
would be like free promo and we expect
this to be spam for example and now we
can try something that we're not sure
about so for example we can you can we
can ask like PI data is really cool come
over so you know what to expect here of
course embassy that was short and sweet
thank you very much